peu
[Musique]
ils viennent de loin
par les chemins de l'enfance biais jours
dans l'eau mais venir y danser
d
petit que sa soeur
[Musique]
le projet aventure
est pas mort
romantique à sanaa
la cloche
erreur
oui corps
je hais
sans eau
au printemps
de la terre
à l'espoir
[Musique]
au soleil
quand
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça donne du jour toujours
table
que
mais
[Musique]
au plus 2
le jeune homme
[Musique]
et
le
en tout cas ça
la poche erreur
coc
g
[Musique]
300 grosse avoir acquis
dia quoi
[Musique]
enfin
temps
[Musique]
ça
dehors
[Musique]
or
alors
cette armée
un jour on perd buddy fils dont je te
vois sortir le soir à ton âge il ya des
choses qu'un garçon doit savoir les fit
us méritoire
c'est parce que tu crois laissons tout
est la belle comme le jour balkans le
labour
elle te rendront pour les joies pour le
joola
le jour
bonjour jurant ne les verras tu ne peux
pas te tromper
tu voudras du
dire je t'aime tu ne pourras plus parler
en un clin d'oeil vous serez unis pour
le pire et le meilleur du timbre alan
vrai bonheur aux yeux de tant qu'acteur
jour la boue comme j'ai dis à ta maman
tu lui diras en l'embrassant tu es belle
comme le jour
[Musique]
le jour
cette personne
la bourre
[Musique]
ici le public comme dans la rue de la
belle mais le coup
[Applaudissements]
à
le jour ils ont terminé surface
comme l'amour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je t'aime tu m'aimes demandé trois jours
de congé
danseur
monkey c'est pas difficile
on fera un enfant de nilo seulement
avec ennahda
ainsi finisseur qui rend très loin
jenny suffira
[Musique]
moi
la vie
s'endormira du soir
mes droits
lui chercher
bien
ici
[Musique]
tu vois des fleurs
devant
lyon
la visée
tous les samedis
pas en quinze jours
économie
les piquants viendra
à la fin des pouilles
photographie au mouvement qui ne sais
pas
visite
autonomie
et toi et moi
on
samedi
le soir
et toi
aller chercher
[Musique]
j'vais me foutais au milieu des algues
et des corps
mais je reste quand je dis bonjour bien
que je veux mourir c'est ma dernière
surprise party je m'écrase donné un
hulot j'ai un contrat très science quand
céphalo tuffeau g
j'envoie par qui rigole
vite
tu devrais pas en blessé la nuit je peux
pas dormir je suis cuit conneries
lundi tu veux je te chante la mer landes
des gosses
pas très clair en regardant
à tanger qu'un marocain qui fait même
plus à rallumer son globe ça
c'est
sa voix
déçu
tu sais tu sais c'est comme ceux qui
voudraient que je me soigne égard
abandonne son club ce n'est pas tout on
espère
feed mémoire du week-end
yannick
tu devrais t'en blessés
je peux
quel
ce que je chante la mer
pas très clair
j'habite est bien plus belle que maurice
est que bâle comme un pétard qu attend
plus qu'une allumette
[Musique]
enfin
qui aujourd'hui ses ventes
j'aimerais bien quand même changé
si rennes
oh
kirby
tu devrais pas
comment
gaby du match de championnat
l'eau
[Musique]
alors quoi sur l'afrique dit papademos
oh
[Musique]
j'ai tremblé lors et j'ai dû rêver
troupeau
hamon
et je perds
quand gisèle clapton
j'aurais pas dû ouvrir à la rocky corps
d'élite ont l'amertume à venir
tu avais mis
ya dû y avoir d
[Musique]
mais ce cri sonic et pays a un truc qui
fait masse courant peut plus passer non
mais t'as plus qui passe j'men fous iton
par la place à partie
nous
[Musique]
le jtac
plus rien
car en transit restent chose aux cris du
marchand de glaces
non mais t'as vu
je veux faire un tour à la plage
[Musique]
vertige de l'amour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai dû rêver ça
les jeux perrier
[Musique]
je
g
ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dit leizer visible et les bleus du ghana
[Musique]
elle est gardée
oui
[Musique]
ce que je veux
[Applaudissements]
on
je m'allume
moman
surtout le
[Musique]
pour 10,2
ça peut être pas
on
pourquoi voter
que de magicien
[Musique]
et
tout va
je t'aime
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en
en plus nous
pas benoît
on le sait bien
marie
[Musique]
en bas
accueil
[Musique]
il
je t'aime
c'est ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des maris à vérone
le palais
[Musique]
guéant
c'est l'état
[Musique]
à qui
woerth
[Musique]
homo
alors
c'est que perçoit
à qui ce billet
[Musique]
il est bassono
à ces parutions
oh là
[Musique]
dix ans
c'est dans le dos
c'est sûr
pas vous
oh
[Musique]
bowles ont des dents
ça c'est non
[Musique]
mais
là
[Musique]
et
le thunder
[Musique]
oh
allez
[Musique]
bon bien déroulé
sans jamais ça
m
[Musique]
je
bussereau
mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sarr et les jeux de grave
que m
je chantais donc nous couchons manille
[Musique]
oh
du plaisir genre
jamas
wii u et
déçu
parti
pratique
là
perle est
monsieur vous
oh
[Musique]
ça fait ça
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
en tournée
les
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
allah
alors
je danse
à oman
ok
[Musique]
et